لبنان و اتحول لك جيفار هل في الجانب
الاسرائيلي هناك اي معطيات جديده بخصوص
عمليه الاغتيال هذه والذي تزامن الاعلان
عنها مع تواجد نتنياهو في مستوطنه كريات ش
مونا على الاقل وفق هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
وايضا مصادر اعلاميه اسرائيليه وسيله نقدا
سواء عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين او مصادر
لبنانيه حسب وصفهم
بان القائد الميداني حسام طويل كان مسؤول
عن عمليه قصف موقع ميرون على جبل الجرمق
هذا الموقع الذي قصف اول امس ويعد من اهم
المواقع الاستراتيجيه المسؤوله عن
المراقبه في الملاحه الجويه في منطقه هلال
الخصيب وايضا تركيا وبالتالي هي تعتبر ان
عمليه الاغتيال وكانها رد على هذه العمليه
وبالتالي اغتيال الشخص المسؤول عن هذه
العمليه ولكن كما استمعنا من مازن قبل
قليل ف ل الطويل باع طويل ايضا في
العمليات لذلك يبدو قد ينتقل ذلك الى ما
صرح به رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بدايه في
موقع حرام
769 حين قال ان لبنان ارتكب خطا
عام
2006 بحق اسرائيل والان هو
يعاود القيام بهذا الخطا مره اخرى بالطبع
منذ لحظه الاعلان من قبل حزب الله عن
عمليه الاغتيال على الاقل خلال الساعه
الماضيه دوت صافرات
الانذار على في البلدات الحدوديه على طول
الخط الشريط الحدودي على الاقل ثلاث مرات
تم خلالها دوي صافرات الانذار في بلدات
ومواقع عسكريه بالطبع ايضا كان نتنياهو قد
وصل
الى موقع او بلده كريات شموه في ساعات
الصباح قبل دقائق فقط او بعد دقائق فقط من
استهداف البلده بصاروخ مضاد ل الدروع ووفق
صحيفتها ارتس الاسرائيليه اصيب اسرائيلي
في هذا القصف من هناك قال نتنياهو بان
اي بانه جاء واختار القدوم في هذا اليوم
الى الحدود الشماليه للتاكيد على انه عازم
وسيبذل قصار جهده لعوده الامن الى الشمال
وعوده السكان النازحين الى بلداتهم وقراهم
ومواقعهم على طول خط الحدود مع لبنان ولكن
كان هناك ايضا واضح تهديد مبطن لحزب الله
وبالاخص لامين امين عام الحزب حسن نصر
الله عندما قال نتنياهو بان اعطينا لامين
عام الحزب مثال لما حدث لاصدقائه في
الجنوب في اشاره الى حركه حماس وما حدث من
ضمار في قطاع غزه واضاف ايضا اي نتنياهو
في رساله ايضا مبطنه لحزب الله بانه في
عام 2006 قال امين عام الحزب بان اسرائيل
اوهن من بيت العنكبوت والان هو يدرك ما ما
هو العنكبوت وان اسرائيل ترد بقوه و بردود
هائله جدا وبانه مصر ومصمم بالطبع على
الوصول الى الامن وكانت التصريحات
الاسرائيليه خلال الايام الماضيه سواء من
نتنياهو او من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
بانه اما العوده للهدوء عبر الجولات
الدبلوماسيه وال المكوكيه وخاصه تلك التي
يقوم بها ايضا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بين
لبنان وبيروت بالطبع وتل ابيب او حسب
وصفهم من خلال عمليه عسكريه اي الدخول في
الحرب ولكن واضح من خلال هذه التصريحات ان
اسرائيل لا تستطيع ان تكون قد فتحت كل هذه
هه الجبهات لانها تصف انها تحارب على سبع
جبهات من بينها بالطبع هذه الجبهه
الشماليه مع لبنان وكانت قد وصفت كل
المصادر الاسرائيليه منذ بدايه دخول حزب
الله وال وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
داخل الجنوب اللبناني في هذه المعركه منذ
الثامن من اكتوبر بانه ما يملكه حزب الله
هو عر اضعاف ما تملكه حركه حماس وكتائب عز
الدين القسام ولكن واضح الان هناك اليوم
تحديدا لهجه تصعيد وتهديد اكبر من قبل
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه اتجاه ما يحدث
في داخل الجنوب اللبناني ولكن بالطبع تبقى
الانظار متجهه الان الى هنا على طول خط
الحدود وما هو ابعد من ذلك خاصه بعد
اغتيال نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس صالح العاروري واعتبار ان قصف موقع
ميرون هو جاء كرد اولي على عمليه الاغتيال
التي تمت في داخل بيروت في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه والان بعد اغتيال القائد
الميداني في الحزب حسام طويل وبالتالي
ايضا الانظار تتجه الى امكانيه ازدياد او
توسيع منطقه ما تعرف بمواقع الاشتباك في
لبنان اسرائيل كسرت هذه القاعده هذا واضح
ولكن حتى الان نح الانظار تتجه هنا على
المستويات الامنيه والسياسيه والعسكريه
لما سيحدث هنا على طول خط الحدود مع لبنان
وهل سيكون الرد هو اوسع مما هو موجود حتى
هذه اللحظه بانتظار وايضا شيء اخير وسيله
وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مساء اليوم
الى اسرائيل لبدء مباحثات مباشره مع
القياده الاسرائيليه ونتنياهو وواضح ان
الملف الابرز قد يكون الملف اللبناني
والحدود مع لبنان اشكرك جزيل الشكر جفارا
البديري مراسلتنا من الجليل
الاعلى